[Music]
so there is this upscale chinese dim sum
place in uh
new york i believe
it's called julian club
join
shaq was dining there on a date
and yo i wonder how [ __ ] small the
dim sum looks in his hat for real dude
it's fingernail cause it's like for us
it'll look like a croissant and for him
it'll look like this
lazy susan like this
[Laughter]
palming it
i really love the shoe mark
wow that was good
this is so good i'm thirsty just give me
the whole teapot
[Laughter]
he decided he's a lion team but me and
that [ __ ] there it is
he decided to pay for the entire
restaurant while 40 tables wow damn
[Laughter]
well how much do you think the 45 yeah
do that peter luger's yeah i'll see him
doing it that
why did he do that bill came up to 80 so
he was just like let's roll he said all
right it's all on me i remember we ate
like this many people and at the end of
the bill i'm like bro that's gonna be
like 300 bucks it was like 125 yeah
40 tables worth of dim sum at a upscale
place cost a thousand dollars a thousand
dollar scale 40 days of sale yeah dude
that's six 100
times each four thousand double it for
tip let's say it's eight thousand
dollars eight thousand
yeah 40 tables eight thousand dollars
old asian people don't eat a lot though
that's true they just [ __ ] sit there
and talk [ __ ] for three hours okay
twenty five thousand dollars final
answer that's exactly what it was 25 oh
yeah so it's right there
25k
wow i
am awesome
hey go get a lottery ticket today yeah
it's really good come on
oh yeah i did classic check all right
because like shaq
shaq was at like a jewelry store and
then he bought a dude like a wedding
ring for his wife oh yeah
he was also at like uh first of all shaq
bought my wife a wedding ring i don't
know if that's sick or not yet yeah
i yeah rather buy the wedding ring yeah
pay for my wedding
what
the ring it's like everywhere if she
goes for the rest of her life shaq
bought me this
the wedding doesn't [ __ ] matter you
go you go like this together shaq bought
us this
it's together that's true yeah get
together
you tag them every time you take a photo
yeah and then one per it's what am i
thinking how much is together
don't say the number right but in la
well about how much you guys spent on
your rings but in la what do you think
the average price is for an engagement
ring in l.a
or five figures i think just under five
players for l.a under five figures
for the average like eight and nine
grand i don't think everyone's a
five-figure ring person but i think
i think the the average person is trying
to flex though you know yeah which is
why just under five figures like eight
grand nine grand i would think so for
the average person i don't think the
average person is going over 10 grand
for a wedding ring i think it might be
lower i think the national average is
under 2 000 or like even lower than
that's the number
side yeah what about that's what i'm
saying l.a l.a is like that flaunting
trying to be somebody let's say under 2
000. i think i'm like yeah i'm gonna go
over two if there's already chicks
buying two thousand dollar bags they're
like they're expecting way more from
their that's what i'm saying
especially if they're korean and korea
challenge yeah koreans don't count
we judge everybody off their worth of
the ring dude oh he doesn't love you at
all
that's crazy it's a crystal ball i see a
divorce
that's screaming
i get so nervous it's like oh wow that's
okay
yeah
oh it's kind of kind of in the glass
is that your second boyfriend yeah
i don't understand it when some of them
were like really expensive but it's like
way too bulky yeah like it's like how
does that even match your outfit you
know did you guys did you guys choose
the ring or did you allow the girl to
choose the ring
oh [ __ ] that i made ours wow did she
want to be a part of it i i got her
input enough where i needed to build a
pdf two years before i got the ring
because i wanted to make sure that i had
the information right and then i went to
go get the ring what the [ __ ] is
information
i wasn't gonna let it go i like it
it's infrared information
you only see it with the special glasses
on it uh
to get the information
you know what happened we've been doing
asian nations all day we got [ __ ] up
that's the real one
nobody's questioning the fact that i put
alcohol on my finger earlier the
information
i got a pdf right literally no [ __ ]
i literally got a pdf from her because i
was like you don't want me to [ __ ] up
you need to give me the information
right
i get it
two years later thinking like she's
completely free it's all her preferences
yeah i get the ring and i'm holding the
ring for like six months in like the
fifth month of holding a ring and like a
month later i'm about to propose she
gives me new information oh
talking about how she wants a slightly
different ring
that's why you can't trust chicks man
exactly
i literally
said
filipinos [ __ ] it i'm just this is it
and then she had to settle with it and
it was greatness on both fronts
compromise is the best thing in a
relationship yeah that really
compromised though
most romantic guy in the room
don't ask her you want to know what the
average california price is for rings
that people spend yeah what's california
what's up over two there's no la there's
just california
that's not fair though because there's
places in california where that goes
like attitude like redland [ __ ]
fresno
there's like barstow here and then
there's like the [ __ ] silicon valley
here so it's like what do you got you
know what i mean it actually is
9482. what the whole book did i say i
should buy a lottery ticket today
do a solo do solo now
oh [ __ ] wow look at those joints yeah
that was clean hair stayed up too
because it was great i can't even do a
lunge right now fluid in those things
watch me on it limping tomorrow
just so much so i can't do it i tore my
quad
yeah that's pretty good but washington's
still the number one state they spend uh
like ten likes in canada
a lot of money wait 10k is number one
and then the cheapest is south dakota at
three thousand dollars
south dakota south dakota staying south
dakota has its rights this is number 51
south dakota let's do one so what's the
they're under puerto rico
they're under puerto rico what's number
one
washington oh washington wow i think
it's wherever a lot of koreans are yeah
for real dude they upped the bar
the statistics because
there was one girl out that we all know
she had a quarter million dollar ring oh
yeah
but she had a discount oh because
it was like less than because her
husband works in the diamond industry
but still wait but the discount was like
50k or something yeah yeah those
discounts are real they're dope that's
how i got my ring yeah how'd you get it
i was living in china for like a year
and then i met like drake's like diamond
maker guy wow and then he hooked it up
for like a ring did you say drake
did you just do this
right here diamond dealer here drake's
over here
[Laughter]
that's a funny thing that you would
notice
i met drake's diamond dealer guy
yeah he gave you like a 50 off hookup
yeah because like when they give you
like they're when they get the diamonds
there they give you the price there
before they make it american graded
you know what i mean so it like when
they american grade it it triples the
price so i was able to get it before the
triple prize because the china grade
they don't trust yeah but i still got a
certificate for it
sick
man go to china then for your diamond
rings yes sir yeah but then you gotta go
to china though true why why is it why
is that a bad thing i don't know ching
chong i mean
[Laughter]
yeah like you don't have to use your
hands at all
just like that
it actually makes your eyes whiter when
you do it i don't you actually better it
is funny that he calls me ching chong
that makes me laugh i know cause i look
more together
but you're seeing that from an asian
dude especially when his last name's
done
i know dude
so he used to have like reviews out on
yelp and i never looked at the pictures
or anything i just saw like this obscure
asian guy in the photos he's probably
one of the clients or whatever because
his last name is done i thought he was
gonna be like some irish dude i see this
[ __ ] hundred and ten pound age goes
hey i'm make done
i'm like get out of here you [ __ ]
scam you have to say it like that the
first session he was like oh
i'm david and i was like skeptical the
whole time yeah i guess i'm training
good god one two all right
started grilling him how many fights you
have dude it's like i did amateur
fighting oh so you're not a [ __ ]
he tricked me i thought he was gonna be
this like burly white guy or some some
dude and he's just an irish fighter
because when i first met him he was
super super skinny i'll never be a burly
white guy oh yeah i've seen pictures of
you you are so skinny dude
zero out of two how long ago was that
four years ago yeah that's about right
tripped me out when you said four years
ago i was like four yeah it's been that
long like 2018. now before that 2017.
yeah yeah around there so he i started
training with him right when i was about
to turn 30. did you have a picture on
your facebook are you that skinny as a
fighter
no well when you were fighting even even
skinnier than that yeah i was like super
skinny
i think we found it
that guy looks tougher than me bro hey
dude
a thing
you